the young wizard will clemente what's up
man how are you gentlemen how's it going
let's get into uh the onsha metrics this
week uh you start off your newsletter
with uh this whole idea around like the
fed announcing uh the tapering and then
what we're seeing in the futures
perpetual funding rate so walk us
through this do you do you mind if we
start with the first chart like dude we
start with whatever you want this is
your show now what we're looking at here
is a just some price levels and then b
bollinger bands with the wick high high
time frame indicator over it it just is
looking for these volatility squeezes so
you're essentially looking at where
price is getting compressed and aka
where volatility slows down and we're
primed up for an expansion because
consolidation leads to expansion
expansion leads to consolidation um and
and so what we're looking at here is
this indicator identifies when we're
getting ready to have one of these
squeezes um and then the bands are these
are bollinger bands i think almost
anybody who does ta are
is familiar with bollinger bands but
essentially they're looking at the
standard deviation from price and um you
know by definition when price is at the
bottom of the bands price is relatively
low when it's at the top it's relatively
high um and then so yeah what we're
looking at here is these previous three
volatility squeezes we had one in april
um one at the bottom of summer and then
the third one in september
what i want to point out here is a
couple things a the amount of exactly
how much time they take to play out kind
of varies like if you look in april it
took you know a good week or two for
that to play out versus over the summer
it took about four or five days right
and then the one over september in
september took about a week um and then
the other thing i wanted to point out
was
oftentimes these squeezes break out in
one direction to grab liquidity from the
breakout traders before going in the
opposite way um and so it's like if you
look here for example in april we broke
out above the bands so it looked like oh
we're squeezing to the upside right
trapped all the traders that are looking
to you know trade that breakout you know
market makers grab the liquidity or
whales grab the liquidity and then we go
the other direction same thing over
summer would look like we were breaking
out to the downside grab that liquidity
and then we flipped to the upside
and so right now we're sitting smack dab
in the middle between both bands at
least at the time of writing um but you
know that's just something to keep in
mind if you're if you're watching this
moving forward when you start to look at
how the underlying um kind of
fundamentals are looking the first thing
that you wrote about was that uh bitcoin
futures perpetual funding rate how much
before we kind of go into what exactly
that's telling us how much do you look
at like the price and things like
bollinger bands etc uh being driven by
these underlying fundamentals or do you
think that there's some reverse uh
element that people are actually
reacting to price like are they driving
price or reacting to price in your
opinion um when you're actually looking
at kind of like a macro analysis of
bitcoin
well it's both i mean you know some
people sit in like the you know
efficient market hypothesis and they say
everything's priced in you know then
there's people like you know i'm reading
george soros book alchemy of finance
right now and he's talking about
essentially you know people aren't
making decisions based off of what's
best for them they're making decisions
off of what they perceive to be the best
decision for them to make and so like
with that being said i think you know
when we're talking about like news i
mean people are just reacting to what
they think is the appropriate reaction
to the news not necessarily what's the
correct reaction to news um as far as
the fundamentals go i think you're kind
of are you like implying like like on
chain when you're when you're seeing
fundamentals correct okay cool yeah i
mean so i look at it two ways
when we have like we're talking like
supply and those kind of things like
supply getting locked up that those
things or supply you know become liquid
those kinds of things tend to be leading
indicators but at the same time price
can affect uh you know market
participant behavior um you know if we
start to see like
prolonged downtrend you know people that
were
previously really strong hodlers you
know they may you know let's say someone
bought in five months ago right and
they've now become a long-term holder
they bought in now they'll be in june
and so they've held since june you know
they
you know they've held through the bottom
of the the bear but they pretty much
like you know just experienced up only
um and so then you know let's say we
start to reverse pretty heavily well
then you know those what were previously
long-term holders they may say oh well
forget this right like okay i'm out
and because they were just expecting you
know some some major reversal off of the
off of the summer lows and so what i'm
trying to get at is just like
a lot of times on chain is a leading
indicator but there are certain
occasions where you know fundamentals
are are affected by price um or if you
have news events too you know you can
you can see the reaction of that stuff
in the data so it's like oftentimes i
don't really look at news too much i
mean i i i do watch news you know
like major headlines i have like like
alerts on like market watch but
generally speaking the way i kind of
think through that is
you can you can really get caught up in
in
your biases around like news and and you
know it's one thing to keep up with the
bitcoin market but then to try to like
become a global macro you know expert
like that's like you know you're just
not gonna be able to do that and so what
i what i look for is
what is what what are the market
participants actually doing in reaction
to the news and then i can then i kind
of use that as a way to gauge like okay
is you know is the market completely
changing behavior based off this news
well you know maybe that's something
actually serious versus you know we got
china banning bitcoin for the 20
millionth time no one cares right and
you can see that in the data so i i
would say like
i i tend to look at the data to gauge
what the reaction is from you know from
the news or whatever i think that's a
great way to uh to kind of frame it as
to how you look at it all right let's
talk about future perpetual funding rate
what's going on here
right so this is based off the delta
between the spot index so a weighted
average of all the the spot price uh
that's the index and the actual mark
price on the individual perp exchanges
so that's that's the mark price and the
weighted average of all the spot
exchanges and that's the delta between
the two and that's that's used to uh
create the funding rate so what you're
basically looking at is
how aggressive are you know perpetrators
relative to the spot market um and so
we've talked about this
i don't know for probably months now but
what i really wanted to to show here is
that
we got this little reset after the after
the fed announced that they were going
to do tapering you know okay they
decided they were going to stop printing
and it's you know as much money as they
they were you know still printing insane
amounts of money but
uh mark you know market reset a little
bit got bought up uh pretty quickly
after that correction we've now seen
funding come back a little bit i mean
it's not like outlandish you know it's
not ideal i just i don't think there's
any strong signal from it at the time
we're we're you know surprised in past
where i think funding really has um
is actionable is when it's diverging
from price action it's like when you
have a dislocation between let's say
uh price is grinding down funding is
rising you know that's that's showing
you that the the effort that the
perpetrators are trying to exert
is is being overwhelmed by selling from
spot or conversely if price is rising
and funding is is decreasing um
you know those are the those are the
kind of things that i try to look at in
terms of you know when when funding is
actionable just because funding is
positive doesn't necessarily mean it's
bearish right like if the funding is up
that doesn't mean that we're
automatically about to nuke um but
with that in mind where where i you know
do you think it can it could be kind of
like a cautionary thing is when you when
you kind of zoom out and look and see
that we haven't had negative funding in
over a month uh we briefly reached
negative funding uh kind of ironically
on the fifth of of last month uh but
yeah i mean at some point we'll probably
get a at least a slight um you know
flush of aggregated funding into
negative territory um and and i'm not
once again i'm not saying that just
because funding is positive that we're
automatically going to go down but it's
just something to keep in mind you know
we talk about this with soper too right
like at some point it's going to come
back down and retest that one threshold
similar thing with with the you know
with with funding at some point we're
going to get a flush back down to
negative territory and it's kind of just
something you you know look at and say
okay like with that in mind you know
we're in a broader context like we're
susceptible to some kind of flash at
some point from the future you have a
brand new chart that you included this
order book uh uh visual i've never seen
this before so you're gonna have to
explain to us what exactly is going on
here because it looks beautiful but
maybe confusing both to me and to other
people
yeah totally so this chart actually
isn't the the order book stuff um i
think i've thrown the order book charts
in there before i use trading light for
that um but i i've talked about order
books because it kind of relates to the
bottom section so to start off with with
what i was saying about order books you
see a pretty strong confluence of bids
right across 60k across several major
exchanges but as we've talked about
before these orders can be spoofs uh and
so basically like you can use these big
bitter ask walls to generate liquidity
for the opposite you know let's say
i like to use examples to explain things
um let's say you know you you think
price is going to go higher but price is
starting to run away from you near this
huge whale where you can set a giant ask
wall it's essentially the cell wall
and you can kind of cap off the price
right and no retail guy is going to want
to sell into that because it's a huge
order and so what they're actually doing
is is they can use that to actually fill
buys on the other end of that because
they're generating liquidity
right below their their
ask wall in that case or conversely
let's say
the market's starting to go down and
they want to get out of their position
but you know they can't they can't start
market selling because they'll incur a
lot of slippage and price will just
start running away from them what they
can do is they can set a massive bid
wall and they can actually be filling
cells as p as they're generating
liquidity because retail doesn't want to
um retail what doesn't want to sell into
that giant wall buys right um and so
they can use these things to kind of
get in maneuver in and out of positions
it's not as straightforward as
oh you see a big bid a large bid so that
means that it's you know
automatically bullish and there's like a
huge wall of bull whales sitting there
waiting to scoop up coins it's a bit
more nuanced than that but with that
being said um i do think like a lot of
traders are seeing these bids in
confluence with 60k just being a really
strong level like suzu was joking around
saying like the great wall of 60k you
know i think over the last week or so
you've seen that hold up as a pretty
strong level and keep in mind you know
we're just ranging you know the last
couple days um but that 60k level when
you look you know and this this gets to
this chart this chart is looking at all
the liquidation levels so we can see
you know let's say price gets below x
number well there's a lot of
liquidations there right and so what you
see and i kind of highlighted this in
this little black box is all those those
pink lines are showing you there's a lot
of long liquidations and particularly
people who are 25 x long um and in that
in that little cluster there and that's
right below 60k
uh and so what i'm what i'm trying to
say here and and i know i kind of sound
like i'm saying well price could go up
or down right um and first of all you
know i don't have a very strong opinion
about the price in the short term other
than we're probably going to get a large
move because of we talked about you know
volatility's the volatility squeeze
um but with that being said if we do get
below 60k with volume if we see a high
volume breakout then i think you'll
probably start to see these long
liquidations um you know
you'll start to see like a cascade of
longs get liquidated because you can see
all those levels set just below um 60k
in that chart there so this is something
that i've started looking at recently
but have never thrown in the newsletter
before but i look at it in confluence
with funding and then also like uh we've
talked about the convexity that coin
margin open interest has i look at it in
confluence with that so you know like
you know theoretical bear case would be
like an enormous amount of liquidations
under under a certain price level um you
know you're seeing funding rising as
price keeps going down and they're all
coin margined open interest you know
coin margin contracts that are being
opened and you can see that in open
interest like that would be like a
theoretical you know bearish scenario
but um yeah just another thing to use in
confluence with some of those other
metrics
before we continue you're getting better
man i love it let's keep going i can
tell you're learning a ton because
you're you're killing it right now uh
the adjusted sopra we you and i and
sopra we we're just chilling there
cheering super when you walk into the
parties at ecu uh justin sopra what's
going on here
yeah so sober is our spent output profit
ratio so we're looking at when a coin
was last moved and when when it's being
moved now so the we can look at the
amount of profit or loss that that coin
is realizing you know coin last moved at
50k
now moves at 40k just random number um
yeah okay it's realized it's realized
ten thousand dollars of net loss coin
last moved at 40k now moves at 50k it's
realized ten thousand dollars of net
profit and so we can run the ratio of
all the coins that are being spent on a
given day and we get sober which is
spent output profit ratio and then we
we're looking here at the adjusted
version which filters out all the
transactions or outputs uh below one
hour to kind of filter out some of that
noise and then once a and then on top of
that i threw a 14 day moving average
because that really smoothes it out to
give us this broader picture um you you
can look at it in like on the on the uh
on like just the regular daily version
which i do that but you know we're
talking about like in this section of
the newsletter i wanted to kind of
navigate from i try to structure it so
like we look at the short term stuff and
then move more you know more macro so
here i'm just trying to paint the
picture uh of what's that broader
context but you can use the daily
version
what i'm looking at here is we we're
still in bullish territory as long as
we're above one
we'll be bearish once we come back down
below that one threshold um and then
again you know if we come back and have
a have a failed uh retest of that one
line but i remain you know i remain
macro bullish using soper
as long as we stay above this one
threshold because we came back down and
re-tested one as support when we when we
retested 40k whatever a month ago or so
very similarly to as you'll see after
the the september correction before the
major run-up we had last year right in
on you know at the beginning of october
it was very similar we came back down
and retested that one threshold right on
the dot so and then over summer too
you'll see
as i talked about you know bearish uh
you know
bearish confirmation would be coming
back up and and failing to break above
that one threshold after breaking below
which you can see we did over summer so
um yeah i mean it's as long yeah once
again like as long as we're above it i
mean i don't see anything to be entirely
concerned about
when you look at the short-term holder
profit loss ratio this seems to be
following a similar trend
yes this was created by david uh david
poyle i think in the last couple weeks
um what you're looking at is
all the ratio of all the short-term
holder uh the the short-term holders in
in profit versus loss um so rather than
in super we're looking at all the spin
outputs so we're looking at all the
coins the coins being spent on a given
day and the profits or losses being
realized versus in this chart we're
looking at specifically short-term
holders you can look at short-term
holder soaper by the way not to get
confusing but
we're looking at just the short-term
holders and the profit and loss that
they're that they're sitting in not
realizing if that makes sense um and so
it's it's very similar in this in in the
sense that you have this one we have
this one threshold that kind of operates
as this this cut off for bullish or
bearish uh market trends and once again
varied just like sober um in bullish
market trends you want to buy the dips a
long one and you want to sell or or you
know perhaps you know hold off buying
for for long-term holders
the retests from the underside below one
and so right now once again as long as
we're above this one threshold i don't
see anything to be entirely concerned
about in a broader context
when you start to go ahead and look at
the illiquid supply shock ratio out of
all the charts today this is the one i
had the biggest question about it just
keeps climbing and climbing and climbing
and climbing uh is that good or at some
point could we cross over into like no
it's actually gone too high and there's
like a negative side effect
yeah i don't
i think i think there's a couple like
confusion like a bit of confusion around
this a a that and like
b people like to say oh well the ratio
is now at the same level it was at at
64k earlier this year or whatever 65k
when we topped out you know how's that
not bearish
and then also you know how are we at a
higher ratio you know than we are now
when we were in 2017 at 20k
the way the way i look at this is you
just try to think about what is it
showing from first principles it's just
showing that supply is moving to these
liquid entities so it's moving to these
entities who um
sell less than 25 of the coins they take
in or they hold at least 75 percent so
you know they take in four coins they
hold at least three of them um
and so it's only factoring in supply
versus there's obviously a whole another
you know part of the equation which is
demand um and so you know
to me this you know this doesn't
necessarily mean that oh we're at a
certain level that translates to
something in price to me it's just
showing that more supply is getting
locked up i look at it more of like what
does this mean from first principles
rather than looking back at a certain
value and attaching that to price per se
because we don't have we don't have the
the demand equation as well
but you know one thing to note though is
obviously declining a liquid supply
shock ratio is bearish because it's
showing that supply is becoming uh
liquid from entities that were that were
previously illiquid so you know coins
that were previously locked up are now
getting unlocked and or or aka are now
being you know spent into the market um
and so like we're currently getting
above where we were earlier this year
we're reaching like 2021 um all-time
highs which also means that we're now at
the highest point in the ratio since
since we were in uh late 2017 it also
kind of resembles a similar structure
where we had you know this this peak in
like you know the early part of early
2017. i don't can't tell the exact time
um but then you know we came back down
just like we did over summer and then
had another up thrust in that before
having this prolonged downtrend um and
so i would be kind of looking for
something similar if we start to see
you know this this declining for say you
know a week or two on end then i'll
probably get you know
pretty cautious uh because it's showing
you know supply is becoming liquid i i
kind of like to use a liquid supply more
than exchange balances to be honest um
like if if you'll notice like i haven't
really thrown exchange balances in my
analysis for like a good month or two
the reasoning is just because
you're you're so reliant on the
heuristics from whatever like data
provider you're using
whether that's glass node coinmetrics
and crypto quant and you know these guys
are brilliant like they're excellent
data scientists but it's never perfect
because exchanges are constantly
shifting how they're you know holding
custody or or you know how their how
their transactions are like all these
different things are constantly changing
um and so you can never get it perfect
and glass node is missing a couple major
you know spot exchanges one being like
ftx which is a big one for me and so i
kind of like to use liquid supply as a
better proxy for exchange balances
because um you know the the exchange
balances are defined
are in that liquid supply cohort
and so like you can kind of look to see
if liquid supply is is
increasing or declining and so
inadvertently seeing the liquid supply
shock ratio increasing is also saying
that coins are coming off exchanges if
that makes sense that does make a lot of
sense uh we've got this long-term holder
supply shock that kind of continues to
roll over as you mentioned
and i think one of the pieces uh dylan
leclair said this at one point um and
there's some questions that people have
some of you can explain it which is when
you see the long-term holders holding
increases the illiquid supply new demand
comes in price has to go up to
accommodate everyone i think most people
can wrap their head around that but when
you start to see the long-term holders
rolling over and they're distributing
some of the bitcoin into the the market
or into new investors hands that's an as
you put in the letter a natural bull
market behavior but to some people it
feels like that's a bad thing so how do
you evaluate it and kind of explain
what's going on here
yeah totally so
the way this works is that in bear
markets long-term holders are buying
because by definition you know they have
long-term conviction in the asset
they're looking to buy when bitcoin is
discounted when there's no you know hype
and mania around it and that's when
bitcoin tends to be the cheapest and
that's you know in in by definition in
the bear market and so they lock up a
large enough portion of supply that we
get this supply shock effect in the
market and as that as that occurs the
incremental demand is going to have to
keep bidding higher and higher and as
price starts to run up that kind of
initiates the momentum of price in the
market and that's it that's that starts
at the very beginning by the long-term
guys locking up a large enough portion
of supply and initiating that that
supply shock effect um but once that
bitcoin is a highly reflexive asset and
and so you know once once that momentum
kind of takes off
you start to get you know outside
capital come into the market speculators
come in the market retail enters the
market and then the the bull market
basically the momentum has taken a life
of its own and the long-term holders no
longer have to keep locking up supply to
initiate that momentum and so once that
once that kind of uh you know momentum
or reflexivity however you want to
define it kind of takes a life of its
own then the long-term guys can start to
distribute into that strength and so
that's what we see throughout you know
every major peak uh throughout bitcoin's
history saw it in both peaks in 2013
long-term holders locked up supply in
between those those two double pumps and
then sold into the second double pump
again um in 2017 you saw the same
behavior as well as 2019 and last year
and so it's it's
very natural to see these guys start to
distribute as the you know short-term
guys or the speculators are coming in
and buying their bags
and it's also saying that if you're
seeing price appreciation with long-term
holders spending well that means that
new outside capital is now coming into
the market
and so that kind of leads us also to the
next metric that i pulled up the spent
volume h bands it's another way of
showing the same thing
and so we we've talked about the spin
output age bands which is just looking
at the percentage of the outputs on a
given day
but this is actually looking at the
volume um and so this is a bit more this
is a more accurate version of of spent
output age bands in my opinion
you're looking at the amount of volume
on every on every given day that's by
coming from each each denominated cohort
and so when you look at the amount of
volume coming from or the amount of
coins being spent from one month or
older entities you're starting to see
that increase as well and i put a 14 day
moving average on this as well so you
kind of have to you have to have a
pretty strong trend for this to really
reflect in in the chart uh and it's just
another way of showing you're seeing
these older coins um being spent just
like you see in the in the long term
holder supply shock ratio
and so when you start to look at this um
there's this entity adjusted a soul
right which uh you've got here and
what is fascinating as i kind of just
eye it up but again you're much well
versed in this than i am in january of
21 this thing absolutely spiked very
high right and that's where we went from
kind of 10 to 30 and then we continued
on from 30 to 60. why is it that the
entity adjusted a soul would spike
between let's call it like the beginning
of november to january but it wouldn't
spike from january to march like what's
going on there
sure so a soul is the average spent
output lifespan
and so we've talked about several these
different lifespan metrics you know we
just looked at long-term holders supply
spent volume age bans this is another
way of kind of looking at the same thing
except there's no volume weighted to
this you're just looking at all the
coins trading on a given day and just
the raw average
age of all those coins being spent
and so you know as as i think we've
talked about before the long-term guys
don't perfectly time the top like they
don't perfectly time the bottom either
they buy you know into the into into
weakness and they sell into strength
that's why i always say into and i don't
say like they sell the top or by the
bottom they don't perfectly time these
things they kind of average in and
average out um and so that's what you
saw you know at the beginning of this
year yeah they didn't perfectly time
like the 60k top but they started
selling really aggressively and that's
shown by this spike here once we had
that first up thrust up to like you know
or i think it was like the
earlier or mid uh 40k so that's all
that's showing um and then you know
overall you had like increased spending
from these older guys
as we went into the summer though you
saw this decline so you saw less
spending from uh from these from these
older coins which doesn't necessarily
mean that you see accumulation um it
just means that you're not seeing
spending so you know high high spending
from older guys is is a bearish thing
but low spending from from older guys
when we're looking at this metric isn't
necessarily bullish because it's just
saying that they're not spending it
doesn't say that they're buying and so
that's where you know when you look at
like long-term holder supply that's
where that like comes into it comes into
play um but yeah i mean you've started
to see if you look and on the right half
of the chart in confluence with the
other two charts we just showed once
again long-term uh long-term holders or
or these older coins are starting to be
starting to be spent
and then two other ways you want you can
look at it too if you are interested is
uh coin days destroyed and then also
dormancy which is the volume adjusted
version of days destroyed the last one
you have is this on chain cost basis
what's going on here
yeah so this is dylan's metric
i think this is actually one of the one
of the main metrics i'm going to use to
kind of
look for when when we're getting
overheated uh over the next couple
months or or maybe into the beginning of
next year uh by the way like
often oftentimes people like to say or
people ask me like my buddies will say
when when is the bull run gonna end you
know is it is it december is it january
and everyone of course wants to know you
know what's the exact price
i don't really look at it that way per
se what i'm looking for as like an
on-chain analyst is what are the
behaviors that are occurring that that
have previously you know resembled
euphoria or exuberance in the market and
so this is one of those oscillators or
or metrics that you can use to kind of
identify that so we're looking at the
short-term holder realized price which
is the the capitalization weighted by
the last time coins were spent uh or
last time coins were moved um and so
like let's say you're you're roger there
and you bought you know 100 000 btc at a
dollar and you've never moved those
coins well although you know those coins
are now worth billions
if you haven't moved them since then and
realized cap terms it's still only
adding a hundred thousand dollars to
realize cap and so you're basically
getting like this volume weighted
average price
via via on chain uh and so you can then
separate that from from short-term
holders and long-term holders and
compare uh and realize prices synonymous
with with cost basis when we're looking
at this and so it's just showing
the
realized price or cost basis of
short-term guys measure it up against
the long-term guys when the short-term
when the short-term cost basis or
realized price goes below the long-term
holder realized realized price or cost
basis it's showing essentially that the
short-term guys are leaving the market
and capitulating at the very bottom of
the market because you know it's no
longer fun you know bitcoin's not just
going up only and so that's when the
long-term guys really step in and are
dominating the market and are setting
the floor as we talked about
and then at you know along the top part
where we have this this little red line
on the screen and that's showing when
when short-term holder realized price is
blowing out relative to long-term holder
realized price so you have a lot of new
work market entrance a lot of exuberance
et cetera
joey john what questions you guys got
for will will what's going on man
hey how's it going it's going well man
uh so my questions about you tweeted
earlier about the volatility squeeze uh
coming up
so we've seen the last three or four
it's not a directional indicator right
it could go either way but there's been
massive moves uh kind of how are you
looking at this and do you have a
prediction on kind of what's going to
come out of it
yeah like
i think i kind of tried to allude to
this but i don't really have a strong
opinion about the very short-term price
um i think we'll we'll
know more like i know this sounds kind
of silly but we'll know we'll know more
once price starts moving in one
direction or the other um i do think
though that like we've seen this pattern
where prices started to break out to one
to one way of you know of the squeeze
grab liquidity and then gone the
opposite direction so based off that
pattern the last three times i'll be a
bit biased to say like if price starts
to break upwards initially then
probably i'm gonna lean more towards
going down and then conversely if it
starts to break to the downside first
then we'll probably get a
reversal to the upside um but i mean
yeah ben i i don't really have a strong
opinion here about um the short term
price you know i try to i try to you
know just just be honest like if if i
don't know i just you know i just try to
say i don't know you know what
long term hasn't changed i would say
what metrics though are you watching
once that break happens
yeah okay so
funding first of all like that you know
i'm always looking at funding
um liquidations as well some of these
liquidation levels we talked about you
know if those start to get tagged you
know are we starting to see a cascade
kind of start to initiate um you know
obviously like if funding is starting to
rise you're seeing you know more
liquidation levels pop up below then
you're probably going to see further
downside um and then also you know
looking at some of these on-chain
metrics like soaper you know a soap or
bouncing off a one
um
also you know we can look at like
what what's going on with the order
books um or a bunch of bids starting to
step in um cvd the cumulative volume
delta we talked about that last week you
know is is the spot cvd starting to you
know increase aggressively so are we
starting to see a strong spot bid and
people interested in buying um volume
two like if we if if we if we start to
break below 60k and we have really low
volume then we probably are going to see
a reversal like that you know that's
what happened when we were consolidating
over summer um and we had that move down
to 29k it was on pretty much no volume
so no one really wanted to sell down
there
but you know if you see a really high
volume move down below 60k then that you
know we'll probably see further downside
that's that's those are some of the
things i'm looking at but volume is
volume is definitely um important here
gotcha john
well how you doing glad to see you safe
from halloween weekend
can you talk about kind of the whales
and then um smaller coin holders and
what they're doing in this bull market
and what they've done historically like
do we expect to see a lot of long-term
holders and whales kind of distribute
their coins to those new entrance
entrance participants i guess um
or do we expect them to kind of just
hold on
right so i i guess we can start with the
small guys when you look at this chart
this is a pretty easy explanation
you just look at it it goes up into the
right and the reason is because you have
this really hardcore base of people um
that are just dca you know every
whatever couple days or once a week or
they're taking a passive amount of their
income every so often and just throwing
it into bitcoin no matter what you know
they're stacking during the bull market
bear market um of course you see this
uptick a little bit more in the in the
bull run uh but you know generally
speaking it's pretty much just up and to
the right no never any major drawn outs
in that sense um with the whales though
they're a bit more strategic with their
positioning uh when you really zoom it
out you're you know look at like all all
bitcoin's price history and all of their
be you know history of behavior
throughout that entire you know
entire existence of bitcoin what you see
generally is similar to the long-term
holders when they start buying really
aggressively that's usually when we
start to initiate a multi-month rally um
and so you you know you've seen this in
2017 um at the beginning of of the 2019
mini bull run like at the at the very
big at the very bottom of 2018 coming
coming into 2019 you saw a big uptick in
wells holdings um and then also at the
end of last year you saw that behavior
as well we saw that at the end of july
um and so now with that being said you
had whales buying at the end of summer
really aggressively i forget the number
off the top of my head uh but you have
started to see them distribute a bit and
take some profits
and then actually over the last like two
or three weeks they've started
accumulating again so like over the last
call month and a half they've kind of
just been like ranging their holdings if
that makes sense but they really popped
after july and that that kind of
correlates with a lot of the behavior
that you see um like historically
throughout you know bitcoins bitcoin's
existence is that they kind of are the
ones well by definition they're the big
buyers right they initiate these these
you know multi-month rallies
and i wouldn't be surprised to see uh
you know whales distributing i've
actually kind of been surprised that
they've started buying again over the
last like month and a half to be honest
because usually you start to see them
distribute throughout all of the
strengths throughout the the bull run um
when you when you look at like we're
just talking about like you know bitcoin
supply distribution over time when you
take up you know when you take the
percentage of bitcoin supply that's held
by the small guys so you're looking at
like 10 btc and less and you plot that
out what you see is that retail holds a
larger and larger portion of supply over
time
and so this this is one way to look at
you know although bitcoin is still very
young the supply distribution is heading
in the right direction you get a lot of
these people like uh you know they'll
come out and post like bad data usually
based like around addresses that'll say
oh well you know
x amount of bitcoin supply is held by
this small amount of people which is
complete nonsense right because all
those those large addresses or even if
they're using like any of these data but
usually these people
you know by definition because like
usually they don't know what they're
talking about they're using addresses um
you know there's like exchanges or
custody solutions it's like
well yeah i mean they're holding bitcoin
for like hundreds of thousands or
millions of people when you're talking
about like you know coinbase or or
binance um
or you know if it's like a custody
institutional custody provider you know
they're holding bitcoin for you know
several different clients with large
holdings you have like grayscale right
who holds like over 600 000 btc so you
know it's it's more nuanced than like
some of these people who try to say like
bitcoin supply distribution is so
concentrated it's not it's definitely
not perfect it's definitely not you know
completely ideal but it's trending in
the right direction and over time i
think we'll get there just because you
know
throughout bitcoin's monetization you
know you're gonna have people who got in
earlier on um and this is this kind of
sounds like a ponzi scheme i'm not even
gonna lie but this is just how this is
how all markets work the people who get
in earlier you know they're gonna sell
once they're once they're way up right
you know either they're gonna reinvest
their assets into something else once
bitcoins monetization slows down then i
think you know you'll you'll start to
you'll start to distribute bitcoin into
you know stocks or um
you know other like business ventures
once we have better valuations on these
things and like we have interest rates
based off of bitcoin and not just like
manipulated fed nonsense um but yeah i
think over time though you'll you'll see
this supply distribution continue to to
trend in the direction it is cool
appreciate that
well when you think about where we are
right now it seems like you are a
short-term question mark long-term
bullish fair
yeah for yeah this week definitely yeah
all right wait you're smiling like
that's like a is that a good thing a bad
thing but
i i don't know i just like usually i
kind of have a strong opinion when i
come on here but yeah this week not
really
i think you're doing a great job man um
all right any any uh fun plans this
weekend
uh just taking it easy i'm gonna watch
the the ufc card so that should be fun
let's get it you're gonna get in the
cage at some point
hell no
[Laughter]
all right man listen i appreciate you
coming on anyone at this point who does
not follow will uh you may be asleep at
the wheel uh let me get your uh your
twitter account 368 000 followers whoa
what i said when i tell you guys he's
gonna end the year at 500 yeah
and no one believed me huh
well i need you to keep tweeting man we
can uh we can't we can't have you uh
should come up short 500k by the end of
the year 368. that means that he could
get
30k through the end of this month and
have 100k december
bang bang there we would be
i wonder what portion of people are
following me now just for the frog memes
i mean the memes are great
your folder must be stacked with those
things
[Music]
yeah wait hold on
before we log off
by the way if you guys thought that
we'll like don chain metrics wait till
you hear about his meme obsession
a whole phone
dude you're a legend i love it all right
buddy thank you so much for uh for
coming on anyone who uh who does not
follow will please go follow him his uh
newsletter is linked there in his
twitter account uh with blockwear go
check out uh all the great work he's
doing he just continues to
uh do a fantastic job well thanks for
coming on today you brought the heat
thanks man appreciate you guys all right
buddy we'll talk soon all right take it
easy have a good weekend later